solve the equation 5 over 2x minus 4
over 3x is equal to 7 over 18. and they
tell us that x can't be equal to 0
because that would make these two
expressions here undefined hopefully the
answer here is not 0 and then this
becomes just kind of extra unnecessary
information so let's figure out how to
solve this so a good place to start i
don't like having x's in my denominators
so let's multiply and in fact in general
i don't like having fractions in my
equation so let's see if we can multiply
both sides of this equation by some
things that will get rid of the
fractions let me just rewrite it so we
have some space 5 over 2x
and then we have minus
4 over 3x
is equal to 7 over
7 over 18.
now if we want to get rid of if we want
to get rid of the 2 in the denominator
here we could multiply everything by 2.
if we want to get rid of this 3 in the
denominator we could multiply everything
by three
if we want to get rid of this 18 in the
denominator we can multiply everything
by 18 and 18 also includes a two and a
three you know prime factorization of 18
is two times nine which is three times
3. so when you're multiplying both sides
of the equation by 18 you're actually
multiplying it by a 2 and a 3 and
another 3. so let's just multiply both
sides of this equation by 18
so if you multiply it by 18 so i'll
multiply this term right here by 18
and then this term right here by 18
that'll get rid of all of these numbers
in the denominator right 18 divided by 3
is 6 18 divided by 2 is 9. but we don't
just have numbers in the denominator we
also have these x's in the denominator
so let's also multiply both sides of the
equation by x so that we get rid of
these so we're essentially going to
multiply both sides of the equation by
18x
18x we're taking essentially the least
common multiple of 2x 3x and 18. this is
the smallest number that is divisible by
all three of these characters now when
we do that
our denominators will disappear x
divided by x is 1 18 divided by 2 is 9.
so this term becomes 9 times 5 which is
and then this term right here x divided
by x is 1. 18 divided by 3 is 6. so you
have 6 times 4 is 24 but you have a
subtraction sign here so minus
is equal to
is let me do that in that yellow is
equal to and then you have this term
7 over 18 times 18x well the 18s cancel
out and you're just left with 7 times x
is equal to 7x and now this becomes a
much much simpler equation now what's 45
minus 24
it is see 45 minus 20 would be 25
45 minus 20 would be 25 then you
subtract 4 more it's 21.
so you get 21 is equal to 7x
divide both sides by 7
and you get x is equal to three x is
equal to three x is equal to three and
let's verify that that works
so we have five over two x so that's the
same thing as five over two times three
minus four
over 3 times 3. so this is 5 6
5 6
minus 4 over 18. sorry 4 over 9
4 over 9. we want to find a common
denominator 18 is the least common
multiple of 6 and 9. so let's put it
over 18
over 18. 5 6 is the same thing as 15
over 18 multiply the numerator and
denominator by 3. 4 9 is the same thing
as 8 over eighteen multiply the
numerator and denominator by two
fifteen minus eight so this becomes
fifteen minus eight over eighteen which
is equal to seven over eighteen so it
works out five over two x when x is
equal to 3
minus 4 over 3x when x is equal to 3 is
indeed equal to 7 18. so we're done